[Música]
a muchas personas les da pena and es
decir cuando no entendieron
especialmente si lo tienen que repetir
varias veces
culpable yo era una de esas personas
pero ahora lo que noto cuando le digo a
alguien más que no entendí es que lo que
hacen es repetir lo mismo pero alzando
el volumen de la voz como si yo no
hubiese escuchado son dos cosas
distintas
una de mis frases favoritas del libro ni
me explico ni me entiendes
dice la vida es como un eco si no le
gusta lo que recibe
presté atención a lo que emite
de hecho el autor xavier guix utiliza el
tuteo yo lo cambié al usted y no porque
fuera necesario sino porque es la forma
en la que me siento me siento más cómoda
al conversar es parte de mi esencia ser
formal es lo que emite y cuando alguien
más me lo comenta me doy cuenta de que
me prestaron atención
esto también me recuerda la teoría de mi
baby un profesor que en los años 70
propuso que nuestro cerebro absorbe
significado de la siguiente forma
7% de las palabras
38 por ciento del tono de la voz y 55%
del lenguaje corporal
pero él explicaba que esto solo aplica
cuando comunicamos emociones y aunque
todavía no podemos leer mentes si
sabemos cuáles son nuestras intenciones
entonces lo podemos utilizar al iniciar
conversaciones o para prestar atención a
la reacción de la otra persona
hablando de comunicación
personalmente no me gusta encasillar la
como buena o mala sino en reconocer las
interferencias que nosotros creamos y
como este no es un tema sencillo
empecemos por lo más básico las
definiciones si utilizamos el
diccionario comunicar es
conversar hacer saber algo a alguien
para mí
comunicar es un proceso interactivo que
se compone de dos elementos la intención
del ponente y lo que entiende el
receptor
como traductora soy fanática de los
diccionarios pero son solo una
herramienta para hacer mi trabajo
siempre necesito contexto
y entonces qué es una interferencia
es un obstáculo o una barrera que impide
que este proceso fluya
correctamente
este es mi charco tengo aproximadamente
13 años investigando una maestría en
traducción y entre la mezcla de lo
profesional y lo académico es que he ido
descubriendo todos los elementos que
perjudican la transmisión del mensaje
mientras me preparaba para estar aquí
hoy me encontré un estudio que hicieron
con los vídeos de texto y descubrieron
que los que tenían más interacción eran
donde los conferencistas dieron su
charla de forma más genuina
es decir la gente se interesa más cuando
la persona al frente está haciendo
sincera la audiencia puede sentir la
confianza
ahora yo quisiera contarles algunas de
mis experiencias por varios años estuve
involucrada en el proceso de
reclutamiento de profesionales de letras
cuando aplicamos a un nuevo puesto de
trabajo el currículum es nuestra carta
de presentación
y en mi caso cuando notaba una gran
cantidad de fallos éstos me podían
indicar que los candidatos no mostraban
atención al detalle
organización ni habilidades de
comunicación
casualmente hace unos días alguien me
decía que no había nada que hacer si la
otra persona no entendía su mensaje
a esta forma de no responsabilizarse de
sus secciones se le conoce como de es
comunicar un fenómeno entrando en lugar
de hacer todo lo posible por entendernos
mejor
lo que hacemos es complicar más el
asunto porque solo mi punto de vista
importa
y este mismo obstáculo sucede en la vida
familiar
de hecho le podemos decir barrera porque
normalmente esa es la palabra que usamos
cuando no nos entendemos con la familia
con la pareja o hasta las amigas
bien aquí no ha escuchado el típico
es que me han lastimado tanto que
construí una pared
bueno amiga date cuenta en mi caso yo le
diría a mi amiga dese cuenta cómo lo va
a entender la otra persona
si usted misma está entorpeciendo el
proceso de comunicación
y qué pasa con los adolescentes que
también tienen estas paredes le toca a
toda la familia
derrumbarse
practicando la escucha activa
y si pensamos en otras dinámicas de
autoridad hay otra teoría muy conocida
que es la de retener o entregar el poder
con la postura
en este caso poder es la habilidad de
llevar algo a cabo de principio a fin
yo entrego mi poder cuando me agacho veo
el piso y en cojo mi cuerpo
al contrario retengo el poder cuando veo
a las personas a los ojos cuando mi
postura es alta y ocupa un espacio
amplio
y esto mismo lo podemos aplicar en la
virtualidad especialmente ahora que los
envíos en redes sociales y los
videollamadas son parte de nuestro día a
día
en esos casos mi cara debería abarcar el
50% de la pantalla porque si me siento
lejos y mi audiencia no me puede ver lo
que género es una sensación de sospecha
y ahora les voy a contar
un secreto
las mejores comunicadoras no
necesariamente son las personas más
extrovertidas
que lo diga yo que soy introvertida y
aquí estoy
y las que tienen el talento natural para
hablar en público esto obviamente ayuda
pero una comunicación eficaz sucede
cuando me tomo el tiempo de entender a
mi audiencia
yo sé que esto hoy en día es un lujo
porque vivimos de forma acelerada
estamos acostumbrados a recibir
información de forma inmediata es decir
llevamos la hipercomunicación del
internet a la vida real
obviamente es más fácil publicar un
mensaje en internet de feliz cumpleaños
y recibirlos me gusta y los comentarios
de hasta desconocidos
en minutos
que llamar a la persona
preguntarle cómo está y estar dispuesta
a escuchar lo que sea que vaya a decir
justamente acabo de descubrir un nuevo
movimiento el de la comunicación pausada
en él ellos explicaban que no se trata
de hablar lento sino de entendernos
mutuamente y esto es lo que a mí me
parece más valioso de esta conversación
para eliminar las interferencias
hace falta un compromiso de esfuerzo
no sé si ya lo notaron pero he tratado
de practicar varias de las cosas que les
he estado mencionando aquí al frente
muchas veces no es que algo esté mal
escrito o utilizaron la pronunciación
incorrecta
sino que estamos acostumbrados a hablar
de forma tan automática que no nos damos
cuenta de que lo que decimos no tiene
sentido porque no estamos usando ningún
filtro de orden ni de lógica
mi recomendación
es hacer una pausa
porque ni el silencio ni la duración del
mismo
son la meta sino que éstos me van a
ayudar a incrementar la calidad de mi
mensaje
obviamente es más fácil decirlo que
hacerlo
pero esa pausa no solo me va a ayudar a
entender a los demás sino que también va
a decir mucho de mi propia forma de
comunicar
muchas gracias
[Música]